WITH GERALDO, JESSE WATTERS,
DANA PERINO, "THE FIVE."
♪ ♪
SO, HOW ABOUT THAT DEBATE?
AWESOME, RIGHT?
IT TURNED OUT ALL THE NEEDED WAS
A LITTLE CHUM TO GET THE SHARKS
EATING.
AND THAT IS WHAT BLOOMBERG WAS.
HE GOT EATEN ALIVE.
>> A BILLIONAIRE WHO CALLS
WOMEN’S FAT BROAD’S AND NO, I’M
NOT TALKING ABOUT DONALD TRUMP.
I’M TALKING ABOUT
MAYOR BLOOMBERG.
>> I THOUGHT HE SHOULDN’T BE
HIDING BEHIND HIS TV ADS.
>> STOP AND FRISK THROWING CLOSE
TO 5 MILLION YOUNG BLACK MEN UP
AGAINST A WALL.
>> WE ARE SICK AND TIRED OF
BILLIONAIRES LIKE MR. BLOOMBERG
SEEING HUGE EXPANSIONS OF THEIR
WEALTH WHILE HALF A MILLION
PEOPLE SLEEP OUT ON THE STREET
TONIGHT.
>> MAYOR BLOOMBERG, WHO THINKS
HE CAN BUY THIS ELECTION.
>> WE HAVE VERY FEW
NONDISCLOSURE AGREEMENTS --
>> HOW MANY IS THAT?
>> I HAVEN’T SEEN SOMEONE LOOK
MORE OUT OF PLACE AND
SUGGEST HE WENT TO CONFESSION.
MEANWHILE, THOSE WHO FEASTED ON
MANY MIKE BENEFITED.
NOT ONLY DID BLOOMBERG NOT HAVE
A BOX, HE DIDN’T KNOW HOW TO
BOX.
CAUGHT FLAT-FOOTED EACH TURN, HE
HAD THE AGILITY OF A CORPSE.
BIDEN FOR ONCE SEEMED
SEMICOHERENT.
AMY TOOK THE CHANCE TO DISMANTLE
THE WORD FAUCET THAT IS BURNING,
BUT EVERYONE WANTED A PIECE OF
THE BILLIONAIRE.
SANDERS IS LIKE A MAGICIAN
BENEFITING FROM MISDIRECTION.
HERE, EVERYONE, LOOK AT
LAUGHABLE MANY MIKE WHILE I
STEAL THE NOMINATION.
OF COURSE HE HAD IT COMING.
YOU DON’T ENTER LATE IN THE
GAME, THROW CASH AT THE CROWD
UNTIL THOSE WHO ARE ALREADY
PLANNING TO DROP OUT BECAUSE YOU
ARRIVE.
PLUS, HIS REPUTATION AS A BIGOT
BUT IT IS A SOBERING
OBSERVATION.
IT’S WORSE BEING A BIG
BUSINESSMAN THEN BEING A AN
APOLOGIST FOR THE COLD WAR
BECAUSE THAT WAS A LONG TIME AGO
SO MAYBE BERNIE JUST FORGOT,
LIKE ALL OF HIS SUPPORTERS DID.
THAT IS SCARY FOR THE REST OF US
WHO PREFER CAPITALISM OVER
SOCIALISM, WHO ROOTED FOR
AMERICA, GOT THE USSR IN THE
’70s AND ’80s, WHO SEE
SUCCESS IN JOB AND PROFIT CAN
ACTUALLY CHANGE LIVES.
SADLY, BLOOMBERG WORKED HARD AND
ALL HE GOT WAS RICH.
HE NEVER STOOD A CHANCE.
CAN WE JUST ADMIT THAT THAT WAS
SO MUCH FUN?
IT WAS SO MUCH FUN.
I WAS HAVING A BLAST LAST NIGHT.
>> IN MY PRIVATE TIME I WATCH
SUPER CAR CRASH FAILS WHERE YOU
HAVE THIS ARROGANT RICH GUY GET
BEHIND THE WHEEL ABOUT SIX,
SEVEN FIGURE CAR BECAUSE HE IS A
CLOWN AND A JERK AND FULL OF
HIMSELF HE WRECKED THE CAR
IMMEDIATELY AND I DERIVE
DEEP, IMMENSE AMOUNTS OF
PLEASURE FROM WATCHING THAT BUT
EVEN LAST NIGHT, THIS WAS SO
AWKWARD AND PAINFUL.
I THINK PEOPLE WILL HAVE PITY ON
HIM AND THEY WILL GIVE
MICHAEL BLOOMBERG A SECOND
CHANCE.
BUT I’VE BEEN WHERE HE IS BEEN.
YOU ARE GETTING UP THERE IN AGE
AND ALL YOU ARE THINKING ABOUT
IS, DON’T BE A -- DON’T YELL AT
IN YOUR OWN NOGGIN.
>> Greg: DO YOU THINK THIS
HURTS HIM?
DO YOU THINK IT KNOCKS HIM OUT?
>> Dana: I DON’T THINK IT
KNOCKS HIM OUT AND I THINK HE
SPENT SO MUCH MONEY IN THE RACE.
THERE WAS A BIG TURNOUT FOR
PEOPLE WHO WATCHED LAST NIGHT.
THIS WAS NOT YOUR AVERAGE
PRIMARY DEBATE.
PEOPLE THAT TUNED IN SAW MIKE
BLOOMBERG FOR THE FIRST TIME ON
STAGE RATHER THAN JUST IN AN AD
I MAYBE THEY WOULD SAY, GOSH,
MAYBE HE IS NOT THAT GREAT BUT
HE PICKED UP THESE FOUR
CONGRESSIONAL MEMBERS, ANOTHER
ONE IN SOUTH CAROLINA AND THE
THING IS, IF HE DIDN’T HAVE TO
DEBATE AGAIN BEFORE THE VOTING,
MAYBE HE COULD’VE HUNG ON BUT
THERE IS ANOTHER DEBATE IN FOUR
DAYS.
I KIND OF WISH THAT HE HAD JUST
LET HIS INSIDE VOICE OUT.
>> Greg: LIKE TRUMP DOES.
>> Dana: STOP AND FRISK,
ACTUALLY, LET ME SET THE STAGE
HERE.
HE WAS PRETTY GOOD AT TELLING
THEM NOT TO INTERRUPT, HE DOES
NOT LIKE TO BE INTERRUPTED AND
ELIZABETH WARREN, YOU KNOW SHE
SAYS SHE HATES BILLIONAIRES SO
MUCH, SHE WAS NOT GOING TO TAKE
MONEY FROM BILLIONAIRES.
GUESS WHAT HAPPENED TODAY?
THERE IS A SUPER PAC THAT WANTS
TO DONATE AND HER NAME AND SHE
IS NOT GOING TO DISAVOW IT.
EVERYBODY HAS TO PLAY THE GAME.
>> Greg: WHERE DO YOU PUT THIS
IN PERFORMANCES OF DEBATES YOU
HAVE SEEN?
>> Geraldo: HORRIFYING AND
SHOCKING.
I WAS AT 21, I HAD LUNCH WITH MY
BUDDY AND HE SAID WHAT THEY ARE
SAYING ON WALL STREET IS THAT HE
BROUGHT HIS WALLET TO A KNIFE
FIGHT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: THAT’S GOOD.
>> Geraldo: I THOUGHT IT WAS A
SHODDY PERFORMANCE BY
MAYOR BLOOMBERG.
I THOUGHT HE WAS UNPREPARED.
HOW COULD HE NOT BE READY FOR
THE OBVIOUS ATTACK THAT YOUR
GRANDMOTHER KNEW WERE COMING.
I THOUGHT, THAT WAS THE PART
THAT SEEMED MOST SHOCKING TO ME,
HOW WOEFULLY UNPREPARED HE WAS.
I MEAN, IF YOU HAVE A STAFF OF
40,000 PEOPLE, AT LEAST HALF
LIKE, TWO GUYS TO GIVE YOU SIX
ZINGERS TO USE OVER A TWO HOUR
DEBATE BEAUTY KNOW IT’S GOING TO
BE ABOUT STOP AND FRISK.
HAVE AN ANSWER FOR STOP AND
FRISK FOR YOU KNOW IT’S GOING TO
BE ABOUT BUYING YOUR WAY INTO
THE RACE, HAVE AN ANSWER FOR
BUYING YOUR WAY INTO THE RACE.
TALK ABOUT THE STRUGGLE, TALK
ABOUT YOUR FAMILY HAD NOTHING IN
THIS IS THE AMERICAN DREAM AND
WHY ARE WE PUTTING DOWN THE
AMERICAN DREAM, AND HOW DID WE
BECOME THIS NATION OF MEDIOCRITY
WHERE SUCCESS IS SOMEHOW
SOMETHING TO BE SHUNNED?
I THOUGHT IT WAS REALLY VERY
AMATEUR.
>> Greg: HE WASN’T A GOOD
PROPONENT FOR CAPITALISM.
THAT WAS THE PROBLEM.
DO YOU WANT TO RESPOND TO
TRUMP’S TWEET ABOUT THIS OR
WOULD YOU LIKE TO GIVE YOUR
THOUGHTS EXTEMPORANEOUSLY
CUSTOMER ASKED WELL, I DON’T
CARE.
REMEMBER YESTERDAY WHEN GERALDO
SAID HE WOULD LIKE TO HAVE A
GREAT NIGHT.
I DIDN’T FORGET.
>> Geraldo: I HAVE VERY SHORT
TERM MEMORY LOSS.
>> Jesse: YOU ARE LIKE
AMY KLOBUCHAR, YOU CAN’T
REMEMBER NAMES.
>> Greg: THE PHRASE YOU KEPT
HEARING IN THE MEDIA WAS
CIRCULAR FIRING SQUAD, WHICH IS
A CLICHE OF COURSE.
IS IT BAD OVER OFF OF THE
DEMOCRATIC?
>> Jesse: KNOW, I WOULD SAY HE
INJECTED A LITTLE ADRENALINE
INTO THE FIELD.
THEY STARTED SHOWING THEIR
TEETH, THEY GOT A LITTLE
COMPETITIVE.
HE WAS LIKE TRUMP LIGHT.
HE IS LIKE A WEAK REPUBLICAN.
THEY GAVE HIM A NICE, FAT TARGET
AND THEY TOOK ADVANTAGE OF
IT, BUT HE PAID $400 MILLION FOR
THAT BEAT DOWN.
MAYBE HE IS INTO THAT KIND OF
THING.
>> Greg: I WOULD’VE DONE IT
FOR HALF THAT.
>> Jesse: I KNOW, HE PROBABLY
WISHES HE HAD A LITTLE BOX TO
CRAWL UNDER AFTER THAT
PERFORMANCE.
HE JUST DIDN’T LIVE UP TO THE
HYPE.
THE GUY WAS SHAKY, HE WAS
UNPREPARED, AND WHAT YOU WANTED
TO SEE OUT OF MIKE, YOU TALKED
ABOUT THIS, YOU JUST MENTIONED
IT.
YOU WANTED TO SEE A BOSS OUT
THERE AND HE ACTED LIKE AN
INTERN.
IF LIZ WARREN SAYS SHOW US YOUR
NDA HE SHOULD’VE SAID, NO, YOU
SHOWED US YOUR DNA AND THAT
DIDN’T WORK OUT.
>> Dana: YES!
>> Jesse: IT’S NOT THAT HARD.
YOU CALLED THIS WOMAN A HORSE
TOOTH LESBIAN, HE SHOULD’VE SET,
ONLY THE ROYAL FAMILY.
>> Geraldo: ONLY ROSIE
O’DONNELL.
>> Dana: HE ALSO COULD HAVE
SAID, HIS CONSULTANTS THAT COULD
HAVE GIVEN HIM A LINE, HE
COULD’VE SAID, DIDN’T LAST WEEK
YOUR STAFF IN LAS VEGAS LEAVE
BECAUSE OF A HOSTILE WORKPLACE?
BECAUSE THAT HAPPENED.
>> Greg: WE SHOULD BE RUNNING
HIS CAMPAIGN.
SPENDING ALL THAT MONEY.
>> Dana: IT’S ONE THING TO NOT
BE ON THE DEBATE STAGE BUT HE
ALSO DOESN’T DO ANY INTERVIEWS
TO GET HIMSELF INTO FIGHTING
SHAPE.
>> Greg: THAT DNA LINE IS A
WINNER.
>> Jesse: I WOULD’VE SOLD THAT
TO HIM.
>> Greg: AS SOON AS IT WAS
OVER, THERE WAS A SPOT,, AND
ADVERTISEMENT FOR BLOOMBERG AND
THEN THERE WAS ONE THIS
MORNING WHEN I WOKE UP.
SOON THERE’S GONNA BE SO MANY OF
THOSE.
>> Dagen: HE SET FIRE TO ALL
OF THAT, HE BURNED HALF A
MILLIONBILLION DOLLARS ON THAT D
STAGE LAST NIGHT.
HE HAS TO START ALL OVER AGAIN